many here at the Tony Awards at Radio
City Music Hall here in New York
guys I'm a theater geek so this was a
pinch me moment and here's a taste of
all the fun we had on the red carpet the
red carpet just opened and I'm gonna
give you guys right now a bird's-eye
view
speaking of full circle it was just
announced you're making your return oh
yeah what about getting 30 rock a stage
adaptation thinking Jane dalek musical
to play so where does being nominated
for a Tony rank for you I wouldn't know
what that feels like so we got to talk
about your t-shirt
Stephen Sondheim's Sondheim is rock and
roll
he is rock and roll isn't he also has
been known to smoke OJ but I but it's
more of a metaphor that musical theater
can be it's cool what do you hope
audiences take away who come and get a
chance to see you guys in Angels in
America I mean I hope people come away
with hope for the future hope people
come away remembering the sanctity of
the human spirit the sanctity of all
life on this planet remembering that
we're all connected remembering that
that every single human being is part of
the same human family no matter our
sexual orientation no matter our skin
color no matter our age no matter our
race or where we come from so I think
that is what I want an audience to come
away with to remember that we're all in
this together we are one big community
and we need each other
I mean how excited are you to be a part
of the community once again and be in
New York and like doing theater my whole
family's here I grew up here and I
love being on the stage I love being an
you know live tweeting it's kind of like
theater because you get to get you get
the reaction in the moment but there's
nothing like theater itself and so I'm
just I'm really excited to be telling
story in the room with the audience
again
what's the moment were all gonna be
talking about tomorrow which moment
there's there's a couple that I think I
that I feel really proud of but one
thing that I'm so proud of is our Tony
dreaming initiative that we put on on
social media where people were tweeting
in pictures of them in their in their
shows oh my god yes I'm I'm telling them
to submit their photos I'm telling you
this is like to succeed it's every cat
this is like catnip if that makes any
sense it's like going on to the hashtag
tony dreaming it makes me the happiest
it's fun is hashtag and the funnest
chance to be internally How to Succeed
in Business Without Really Trying
I think I was 17 right now you're
adorable thank you no I should've
brought that bow tie I've been doing
musical theater since I was 10 not
necessarily working at it sure it
started as a hobby but so to be here
tonight I mean I couldn't ask for
anything more
yeah the dream come true really is would
you tell young Taylor who dreamt of
being at the Tony Awards would you tell
her right now I mean some fun because it
can easily feel like a lot of pressure
but I want to enjoy this moment except
in time because you also have to perform
tonight so there's like you know there's
a lot going on yeah we had a show
earlier constantly back into my wagon
out of it but it's so thrilling